>>> DRAMATIC VIRAL VIDEO CHINA
SHOWING COVID TESTERS GETTING
PHYSICALLY SICK, SOME EVEN
FAINTING FROM POSSIBLE HEAT
STROKE.
THEY HAVE HAD TO WORK LONG HOURS
OUTDOORS IN THOSE HEAVY
PROTECTIVE SUITS AMID THE
COUNTRY'S RECENT HEATWAVE.
AND SELINA WANG IS JOINING ME
FROM BEIJING WITH MORE.
AND CHINA GETTING HIT ON TWO
FRONTS HERE, THE HEAT AND THE
SURGE IN COVID CASES.
AND AS WE SAW, POTENTIALLY VERY
DANGEROUS FOR THOSE HEALTH
WORKERS.
>> Reporter: EXACTLY.
UNLIKE OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD,
THIS HEATWAVE IS HITTING A
POPULATION IN CHINA THAT IS
STILL REELING FROM THE HARSH
COVID-19 LOCKDOWNS.
CHINA IS DEALING WITH ANOTHER
SURGE IN COVID CASES BECAUSE OF
THE HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS OMICRON
SUBVARIANTS AND THAT IS PUTTING
AT LEAST 30 CHINESE CITIES IN
FULL OR PARTIAL LOCKDOWN.
AND THIS BRUTAL HEATWAVE, IT IS
NOT ONLY MAKING IT ALL THE MORE
SUFFOCATING FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRAPPED AND SEALED IN THEIR
HOMES, BUT ALSO MORE DANGEROUS
FOR THESE FRONTLINE COVID HEALTH
CARE WORKERS.
SCORCHING TEMPERATURES SWEEP
OVER CHINA TURNING MASS COVID
TESTING INTO A DANGEROUS TASK.
STATE MEDIA SHOWS COVID WORKERS
COLLAPSING ON THE JOB DUE TO
WHAT THE VIDEOS SAY ARE HEAT
STROKE.
IN EASTERN CHINA, A COVID WORKER
VOMITS ON THE GROUND AS
COLLEAGUES RUSH TO TEAR OFF HER
HAZMAT SUIT.
UNABLE TO STAND, SHE IS CARRIED
AWAY.
IT IS A SCENE PLAYING OUT ACROSS
CHINA.
FAINTING, FALLING, CRUNCLYING O
GROUND MOTIONLESS, STRUGGLING TO
BREATHE.
THE COVID WORKER'S LONG HOURS IN
THE SUFFOCATING HEAT MADE WORSE
BY THEIR THEIR HEAD TO TOE FULL
BODY PROTECTIVE GEAR.
THAT IS NOT WATER ACCORDING TO
STATE MEDIA, IT IS SWEAT.
GUSHING OUT OF THIS WORKER'S
HAZMAT SUIT.
THE SWEAT POOLS INSIDE THE
PROTECTIVE GEAR LINING THE
INSIDE OF THEIR RUBBER GLOVES.
THE SURGING TEMPERATURES
COINCIDING WITH SURGING COVID
CASES.
CITIES ACROSS CHINA REQUIRE A
RECENT COVID TEST TO ENTER ANY
PUBLIC AREA, THAT LEAVES
EVERYONE YOUNG, OLD AND SICK ALL
WAITING IN LONG LINES LIKE THESE
IN THE BRUTAL HEAT.
>> IT IS REALLY HOT.
ESPECIALLY EXHAUSTING AND YOU
FEEL LIKE -- A LOT OF TIMES YOU
FEEL ANXIOUS BECAUSE YOU HAVE
THINGS TO DO.
>> Reporter: TO SURVIVE COVID
WORKERS ARE GETTING CREATIVE,
HUGGING GIANT BLOCKS OF ICE,
PLACING THEM ON THEIR BACKS,
LAPS AND FEET.
COLLEAGUES RUB ICE ON EACH OTHER
AND TAPE ICE COLD WATER BOTTLES
TO THEMSELVES.
SOME AUTHORITIES HAVE NOW SAID
COVID WORKERS CAN WEAR PPE THAT
DOES NOT COVER THEIR ENTIRE
BODIES.
DOZENS OF CITIES HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCING RECORD HIGH
TEMPERATURES.
LAST WEEK MORE THAN 80 CITIES
ISSUED RED ALERTS WITH SOME
LOGGING TEMPERATURES OF MORE
THAN 110 DEGREES FARENHEIT.
IN CENTRAL CHINA, A MUSEUM
CLOSED AFTER THE ROOF MELTED.
AND ANOTHER CITY OPENED UN
UNDERGROUND AIR RAID SHELTERS
FOR PEOPLE TO ESCAPE THE HEAT.
AND CROPS ARE WITHERING AND
DYING UNDER THE HIGH
TEMPERATURES.
THE SOIL PARCHED AND CRACKED.
THE DAMAGE TO CHINA'S CROP
PRODUCTION THREATENS TO PUT MORE
PRESSURE ON AN ECONOMY ALREADY
DEVASTATED BY THE PANDEMIC.
BUT IN ZERO COVID CHINA, EVEN
HEALTH CARE WORKERS HOSPITALIZED
FROM HEAT EXHAUSTION GET A
POSITIVE SPIN FROM AUTHORITIES.
THIS PROP BEGAN TODAY OFFICIAL
SHOWS GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
VISITING COVID WORKERS IN THE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT WHILE
SHOWING THE MOTIONLESS PATIENTS
IN BED, THE VIDEO RALLIES PEOPLE
TO WORK TOGETHER FOR VICTORY
AGAINST COVID.
AND TEMPERATURES ARE NOW
STARTING TO EASE UP IN PARTS OF
CHINA, BUT OFFICIALS SAY THE
WORST COULD STILL BE TO COME
WITH MORE EXTREME WEATHER
EXPECTED IN THE COMING MONTHS.
AND ALSO THIS HEATWAVE IN CHINA
FOLLOWS BRUTAL FLOODING IN
RECENT MONTHS THAT HAVE
DISPLACED MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IN
CHINA.
THE GOVERNMENT NOW IS SAYING
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A TOP PRIORITY
WITH THESE RECENT UNRELENTING
TORRENT OF WEATHER-RELATED
EMERGENCIES REALLY BEING A
WAKE-UP CALL TO BEIJING.
BUT THE QUESTION, IS IT ALL TOO
LATE.
>> A GOOD QUESTION.
REALLY FEEL FOR THOSE COVID
WORKERS IN THAT INTENSE HEAT.
SELINA WANG, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE FROM BEIJING.